I'll do it today. Thank you for your
continued support today.
I'm the only one in my family who can work. I need money.
Why on earth would I be subjected to something like this?
[MUSIC] Is this your
first time in the Earth Dungeon? It's okay.  I
'll protect you.
[Music] Let's
start as well.
Attackbegins. As long as you continue to
fight as usual, you'll be fine.
Are you all acting as an empath and learning from your back? I
don't think I'm cut out to be a leader.  But
you have awakened after being a student,
haven't you?The life people hunter has a
big role to play, and there is only one thing to do in order to survive.Please be
cowardly.How long are you going to press on, even though you have saved your life?
How long are you going to keep forcing me to
die in a place like this?  Can
I really become stronger?